[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to GameSpot
live I'm chaste Eva Senseo joining me is
been Janka it's me I'm back yeah we're
back we were here yesterday and we're
here today and today we're playing Metro
Exodus yes launch day for Metro Exodus
so we're gonna plead be playing the game
on Xbox one
brought to you by Metro Exodus so let's
jump into the game shall we
yes so we're we're hang out here we're
playing on the Xbox one X so we've got
the the cool extra processing power that
we need I'm gonna play on normal I've
got nothing to prove because I'm playing
easy so I I am not here to judge you sir
it's the way that I assume the
developers intended the game to be
played so that's that's where we're
going I feel like this is the intended
way to play as well so if you're not
familiar with the Metro series this is
the third game in the series yes and if
you're worried about spoilers we're only
playing from the beginning we used to be
so we've got a little bit of a catch up
here this is kind of a cool training set
up also we've got the subtitles on so we
can talk if we need to let us know how's
everyone's day going yeah happy Friday
to everybody we've made it yeah this
crazy week we sure have game releases
and I'm so happy
big week for games so yeah like I
mentioned this is the third installment
in the series the first two were Metro
2033 and Metro glass lights and this is
Metro Exodus so join us won't you
tell us what you think of the Metro
series in the chat we're hanging out on
youtube so youtube.com slash GameSpot's
if you've got questions about the game
want to do anything in particular want
us to be quiet during the cutscenes does
let us know yeah it'll it'll be a good
time we're we're here for the good thing
about Metro is it's got a very strong
story very strong characters and a very
very strong atmosphere and it's it's a
lot to take in and it's a good thing you
kind of get yourself immersed into and I
also understand that having people talk
over the experience my kind of lesson
into business but that's why you
lock yourself in your room put on your
your nice big coat open a window so it
gets kind of cold and live it out
experience the beginning with us yeah
and you'll know what to expect later
when you're playing thanks for doing
this hey anytime another user let's
listen a bit to the story so you can
catch up so this is underground they're
still living in the metro but our boy
Artyom he back he thinks that there's a
there's there's still people outside
he's going off trying to turn a find him
I believe in him yeah yeah it's really
portion vitam you playing with a card
that supports ray-tracing we're playing
on an Xbox 1x yeah we are playing Metro
Exodus on Xbox one X and yet if you're
not familiar this is a story driven
first-person shooter and it kind of
blends combat and stealth with
exploration and a bit of survival horror
so you're ready to get a little bit
scared excited and yeah let's do this
look at those boys yeah there's some
some real gross looking monsters in this
series and also if if you don't want to
hear more in depth thoughts or even if
you would say a review we have one up on
our site written by Michael it's a very
good review and I highly recommend you
check it out we have after this stream
of course to stay here please yeah we
have the second part of our review
coming up some time today too
so keep an eye out for that so in-depth
discussion questions from you guys
Scorpio Danny says are you on the train
the whole game no you are not and that's
not a spoiler because it was in the
trailers yeah you will go outside I must
choose hope he chooses hope he's got to
find the signal he's got a
the people the people and the signal
yeah so we're playing as Artyom as you
may be familiar with or may not be
familiar with and a little bit about him
he's born in Moscow um a few years
before a nuclear war and he's lived his
entire life in the Metro and on many
occasions he's risked his life to
protect it and so he's kind of obsessed
with the idea of finding life beyond the
tunnels of the Metro as you can tell
from what he's talking about here
so he's regularly venturing outside and
looking for people so he's determined to
prove that there is indeed life outside
the Metro so let's find out if he's
right today this is pretty yeah the game
is very very pretty and it's desolate
out there but even even on the Xbox 1x
it still looks very nice something
beautiful about this this desolate
atmosphere some questions coming in what
do we think of the movement and the
gunplay movement it's it's appropriately
kind of like its a bit slower' it's got
some weight to it which makes sense and
the gunplay it feels pretty good I agree
yeah I'm down with it yeah the movement
feels accurate it feels like I would
move in situations like this gotta go
down inside the tunnels I'm gonna go in
the hole here we go
see you later doesn't even close it
though no that's weird but maybe he
needs some light you know it's very dark
down there that's true
the radiation is still off the charts we
can still hear our Geiger counter going
so you should keep your mask on for sure
just make sure our guns loaded here
we're set we're moving we're doing so
we've got a flashlight got our doors got
some monsters everything's coming
together we've also got our secondary
light here that we can use to light
these spider webs on fire so we can
easily move through them that was not
what I wanted very large we'd be fine if
we don't have any of them show up
anymore it's got to burn all those
spider webs this is actually what our
diems here for is to clear crowd all the
spiders so no one has to deal with them
what take this definitely I need to
reload so you know that we've already
seen these things scurrying around down
here so we've kind of get prepared yeah
we're good everything's way too quiet
more bugs no thank you
all the spiderwebs yeah
that's a very good goal is this the best
atmospheric game you've ever played
I still think metros got some of the
strongest atmospheres in any games I've
played you'd be hard-pressed to find
another one that matches it but it's
it's definitely up there yeah we haven't
gotten too far into this game
yeah we're how much have you played I've
already now maybe like five or six hours
so I'm excited to kind of get more into
it I want to make sure that I kind of
understood what was going on in the
beginning before
yep here we go before we started the
stream and the things just disappeared
so you're gross got him good job
tap tap that button real well got him
yep coal mines that environments look
great yeah they're they're very spooky
there's a lot of good detail around kind
of helping build the yeah a lot of tiny
details I appreciate that see you down
there think you're clever I'll be I can
kind of see like this is this is the the
kind of movement that I'm at right now
there's a lot of weight and heft to
everything to kind of bring that out
hello kang said what years the game set
it's set in 2036 two years after the
events of Metro last light let's head
through this door and see what's on the
other side are you I'm willing to bet
it's not something good oh no do not
well let's lock them in there yeah yeah
yeah we don't we don't need you guys
yeah
punch him stab them no there's more of
all right nice stabbed ahead this whole
part this is it it's real claustrophobic
and real uncomfortable
[Music]
like how I got in his mouth what there
we go we got the the crews all here
thanks guys
it may Artyom does a high-pitched sound
let you know that it's you're hurting
really bad crime asked hey Ben chastity
how are you we're good thank you good to
see you and Metro last light reminded me
of half life I hope the new one has the
same feeling as what he said it's still
got that kind of half-life he kind of
kind of feel to it so if that's true
looking for Dan Dombrowski said game
looks sick yeah yeah try it out today
if that's so pleases you yes we're gonna
be going for for like what now
hour-and-a-half yeah we're playing an
hour and a half until 1:00 p.m. Pacific
time so you'll get to see a nice hour
and a half of this game all right let's
take some questions on the chat right
now so we're on the chat on youtube so
youtube.com slash GameSpot unless so
what'd you think of the Metra series and
which one was your favorite game and
what your hopes are for Metro Exodus
today we are playing brought to you by
Metro Exodus so thank you to our friends
at Metro Texas for providing us with the
game to play today and if you're not
familiar it's developed by 4a games
published by Deep Silver third
installment in the series just to let
you know so it follows Metro last light
so if you played last night you'll be
pretty familiar with what's going on
here and you can dive right into it and
yeah we're playing as already him again
and he's gonna leave the ruins of Moscow
hopefully to journey beyond that's his
goal and yeah we're gonna try to journey
across Russia it says that we're gonna
bond and travel with with traveling
companions recruiting new allies for our
cause and encounter sinister foes in the
waistline
it's a cool back in journal entries this
may be loading my other safe maybe I'll
do a time let's do a time skip site
because you were getting its act I got
that intro we got attacked
we got the build up we'll see here in a
second yeah yeah it's very true her
name's Anna and she is the best sniper
in the Spartan order guys there's still
a habitable place we're doomed to leave
the rest of our lives underground he's
so optimistic that yes I I do love how
optimistic our boy is alright let's see
where we start ahead it might be at your
save and you said you were a couple
hours in I'm a couple hours in not too
far off of where we were but yeah we'll
have a little bit more open to us which
is always a good thanks good yeah so
he's been going outside a lot like what
where are you at in the game
particularly can you describe so we've
gotten the Train and that's where we
kind of held off oh no we're right
that's where we were this is perfect
let's hit it is that the room of doom
that's okay so we can skip past them
you've already seen still feeling real
claustrophobic still feeling real are
comfortable with these things jumping on
yeah
[Applause]
I'm still being able to fight these
things off like this is very impressive
very strong he's playing I was really
attentive but now that I'm just looking
behind you there's a lot of detail is
missing yeah got some fur on him got
crazy eyes
also I get a little bit of like a like
an OCD thing when I say that he left his
knife and sink back that with you don't
abandon that night it just saved you
from like five of those things
thanks buds
looks great on the accent place smoothly
I agree yeah sharp sound again remind
our boy Artyom is hurt real bad he's
having a bad day that's alright here we
go okay we're getting carried away to
the infirmary everyone out of the way
important main character coming through
open it up it's nice to have friends
things shortly will be reunited with our
wife for it yeah she Lucia's the first
person who comes to visit us as soon as
we wake up so we did just come back from
one of our are crazy scouting missions
that everyone tells us not to go on
where we're trying to find those signals
of people who are outside of Moscow and
Colonel is not like everyone keeps
telling him not to do this but he won't
stop give me that blood put Artyom in
smash hey I'm down
huh wakey there she is
reading her book oh so supportive
sitting buried Sam are you awake
it's okay the doctor said you'll be fine
are you trying to kill me with worry
what if next time you don't return from
the surface everyone's worried about no
one to find to talk to if there was
don't you think they'd be here already
[Music]
it's the only the metro transfer we need
to talk by Artem please promise me this
was the last time I'll see you later
getting this tomorrow
can't wait tell you're in for a good
time from the brink but people are
giving you their blood which could save
so many wounded
vacuum radiated don't you think that is
unfair maybe a little bit I can promise
I'll be able to bring you back next time
at least the docs giving it to me
straight
yeah I can appreciate that
so yeah we just uh well I just realized
that we're married to the Colonel's
mm-hmm daughter that complicates things
get even more complicated hello
[Music]
do it you got it uncle are diems on the
case see you later turn that light off
can't believe I can't reach that one but
you guys should turn that one off too
you're not using that there's no one
even in that room and they have the the
lamp lit oh it's the boys this is what
I'm here for everyone out of the way to
see
irresistible to any woman I appreciate
how she's just staring at him as he said
two hours
I'm holding don't leave me
no morals fest there are the game kind
of I haven't seen it come all the way
here yet personally because I'm finished
the game but just talking to Michael who
did the review the game does still have
morality in it it judges you based on
full-on decisions and smaller decisions
as you're making your way through it so
it's still there hey man someone's got
to do it you're gonna be thanking me in
a few years when the Metro is starting
to run out of electricity you know those
candles can burn up that's all these are
finite resources yeah it's like you're
gonna put me out of a job Artyom don't
do this the people need a constant
supply of candles dang
so even she's getting fed up with the
fact that I'm on this wild goose chase
trying to find these people swept that
filter agree I like Artyom's when he
joined it's real good it's actually been
along I haven't thought about this until
just now it's been a while since I've
played a game with the silent
protagonist you know yeah that's the
thing
excuse me I mean the sliding games one
said seems like the game voices are the
same as Metro one and two they sounded
the same I didn't listen to her at all
that's true what was that sound Oh
alert we're not alone I bet we're gonna
get jumped by some scary monsters here
in a second there's got to be some
mutants around whose footprints are they
so I get those headshots the gunshots
I'm really good in this out of here
I deeds it a break dance move I love it
yeah filter swap turn off the Gameboy we
can probably boost the game noises yeah
we check here in the we got males let's
do master volume and turn to many 920
options here we'll just keep it a little
bit different of us a cold cold bus with
this badass couple yeah there's going
out into the radiative zone checking for
survivors it's a lot of them it's not
just what we need you're a liar I also
like how we've still got this dedicated
wipe off my visor whenever I want to
she doesn't even care about all this
she thinks it's whatever say we let him
pass I mean as much as I want to flex my
shooting ability dirty Artyom oh I'll
talk to Robin Jake didn't even see it
this game does look very very pretty if
you're just tuning in we're playing
Metro Exodus its launch day and we're
playing on the Xbox one
brought to you by Metro accident oh and
this is the other thing too there's a
photo mode like that and you step out
here and kind of like take shots
real action shot of your wifey it's kind
of like hanging out here sneaking
sneaking around it's gonna kind of over
this way striking a pose strike a pose
it's a bit of a bit of a joke oh my god
bring it in here bring it down bring it
out in the middle there you go there we
go we got a nice little little centered
thing save it
snap it never forget it screen shot
mr. diarga was a little bit of a joke
and play on words for one of our
GameSpot series we have going on right
now for which is very very clever
mask but I got it let's help her up but
I can't see I'm so cold
canvases how long his game we don't know
we're not you haven't finished it surely
hey I haven't gotten a chance to finish
it yet mastered a face wipe technology
[Music]
that's a whole train whoa who's on that
train whose trains is this that's what
we need to find out so white my best to
make sure I can see what I'm seeing yes
let's start running yes we can now let's
not rush into things
right I see yeah I don't trust these
guys either do I not not even slightest
[Applause]
I didn't trust them and we were right
trust no one that's who's playing it's
me
yeah Ben's playing I'm currently the one
who's I'm just watching everybody
yeah and we're playing on xbox one you
should have read first [ __ ] arty on
thank god these people they're honza not
the order [ __ ] oh they did a number
on you
well good I count on that our village is
about to come to kilometres through here
what village
you're not mosque you're not but then we
got caught by this here you mean there's
life outside why wouldn't there be any
lots of places and Artyom was right but
he did it he knew so I really like how
kind of in the scene you get put with
like like your kind of move around like
you're actually in the back of a car
like in these people's faces like
talking to them it's it's kind of cool
it's true if we could bring the chassis
along with a flamethrower we wouldn't
have even gotten kidnapped in the first
place
absolutely manatee give them their masks
that's right I got this trick and I know
that yeah look
dang that's a mean dog
that's a mean man with a gun ah this is
a bad situation
you think I'm dad you should've
double-tag get up here probably go yeah
yeah I mean I did get mauled by like
five of those creatures back inside the
sewers oh thank goodness there's a mask
right here
steal it this is my master need it
anymore
gimme those are good those are real
breathing sounds oh there's a lot in
this game that makes me just kind of
uncomfortable put in like a good way a
good video game way got me healing I
think we're about to pick up some here
in a second this is kind of like the oh
if you're hurt this is what you should
do
smells everywhere tactical crawling
Blake past some some scary skulls
there's a foot right there yeah there we
go
healed up here feeling a bit better so
this is just that the scary monsters of
the wastelands i stuff in the water too
hard creatures here's that train
yep you'll that train catch up to the
train I'm doing I'm doing I'm going they
don't see me you believe this let me up
will you go in the pipe will surely take
me where I need to go of course
grandma Castillo said what's up
everybody hello how's it going that's
that's also another thing I hear is it's
almost worth going back through this
game with Russian turned on oh yeah for
for the ultimate experience we might
actually have something going on with
that may be in the works that's an
interesting thing to people kremps it
where's our team's wife Anna she's
around a bullfighter again we're looking
for her yeah I think she's still with
those those people who kidnapped us
she's with those guys but we'll find her
yeah worry not there's some boys over
there let's get up this ladder
nope they're gonna see you they can try
to see me I'm too sneaky you know
should an English speaking person play
with Russian dialoguing with subtitles I
think that's a pretty good argument you
could make yeah so my favorite video
game series I play in Japanese with
English subtitles oh they're talking
about a her so they must have our wife
yeah yeah where's she at this guy is
he's fighting the good fight telling
them that they're doing some wrong stuff
hope we run into him and is great okay
dang well the enemy of our enemy is our
friend
so let's steam up what he did but have
you seen my wife hello it is I know hold
up you're darn right how did you pop
through there oh my god I assume that
he's recognized the bullet hole in the
forehead I did it's really hard for me
not to want to respond because it's a
silent protagonist thing and I always
fall into it I'm always conscious of it
but that's kind of like the effect of it
you know
but we may sneak in from the back more
sneaking missions hello sir please drop
the 2x4 I just want to ask about your
cool where can I get one let's do it
this way you sneak through the lightning
battle and disable it well I detect them
hmm I got it solid plan tell me when to
go go now go
okay you're gonna tell me three times
who's just enough da what's going on
it's those lights again stick to the
shadows don't brush I like it these are
all good tips stay in the dark what's
going on what's the big idea
all right now we're upstairs about to
sneak up on this guy over here he won't
even see it coming
excuse me okay yeah sure yeah I got this
I'm already on it I was telling everyone
who's watching I was about to get this
guy you don't need to tell me to get out
[Music]
got him nailed it I've been practicing
turning lights off for years in the
Metro you've probably not heard about me
[Music]
wait
he's looking this way and do we need try
to stealth kill all I'll try to do some
still I'm gonna give it a go no throw it
throw that can pick up that can go
through the door really good at throwing
cans I just wanted everyone to know okay
we'll see you later good luck to you
thanks look at how dirty this is I might
need that
wait till Artyom hears about this
wherever he is Buster Buster I love that
there's yeah knock knock it's me I'm
here oh hello
yeah they're good that uh that moment of
reprieve right there oh my god cher just
shot all the delicate computer equipment
you big dummy take them out
get your wife
you're the one who did this
[Music]
was a conspiracy the whole time talk
this sucks
look at all these places who are
learning that we're here and we're
learning that they're there do we delete
it because I'm so mad that he hit my
wife I'm sorry too we're putting on the
Xbox one X Y a mess somewhat crude done
more wonderful ok let's go let's do it
the train engineer this is uh okay for
another your so hopefully make it their
runner mask let's sneak around mess
people up oh it's so snowy out here
up you go can't really see well with the
snowstorm
don't forget your visibility top of the
sniper so she'll she'll help us out yeah
I'll just sleep around down below also
like how she kick out that light on her
way up to help us so we've got two guys
in the corner this my hide I'm head over
this way let them pass so don't want to
[Applause]
go don't turn me around
yikes that just blew back so far oh okay
so this isn't what we were hoping for
what that means we just get to play it a
different way just keep hiding and keep
taking people up see you over there
you're gonna have to step out eventually
it's that guy over there though go got
him
Ronald - it is there multi-player no
[Music]
mask
I'm a late Brian proud mo already but
it's okay you can avail it could you
pick up from the other guys that you got
down good might be a good thing to go
back and do up here first though I don't
think yeah I'm headed this way
I also got this guy down here I can pick
up there we go and get the ammo we're
back in business
if I did this if I made it all dark it's
a real Batman moment yeah come here
right down there does that guy there
anymore it's wiping mass swapper gas out
here I don't think these guys can even
see me they're just kind of shooting so
just as a kind of a cool way to look at
how this could have been done when I did
this originally I actually stealth
killed everyone in this court now so
this is alternate way to do it Hey
sometimes you gotta you gotta get the
[ __ ] sure the stylist gets messy yeah
I got the guy behind you you don't you
don't stand a chance grab some more of
this ammo down here
James looks an amazing weather effects
yeah yeah very believable Sousa as a
person can just tell how windy and snowy
it is or there was a person who who
lived in the Midwest and grew up with
like really bad snowstorms I love
looking at snow but I hate like actually
living in snow
so I really appreciate whenever games
have really good snow effects it's all
the fun without the hassle I guess you
know there's a guy crossing edge take it
also take all these think we've cleared
everything out
we have reviewed the game
it's uh it's up on the site you can read
the review we've also got a yeah the
second part of our video review coming
up at some point later today I believe
if not today sometime this weekend but
it's it's it's all there for if you want
to check it out the mass permanently
broken on the screen I don't mind
be kind of cool just checked for you on
the site if you wanna check it out after
this stream here we go we've got a got a
new site for our stealthy pistol that's
cool
maybe something hidden over here I
didn't actually I didn't check this out
when I went through here for the first
time they asked if your mass is
permanently broken until you get a new
one right maybe I'm not I'm not sure how
it works
let's just uh grab this bring it up grab
that ammo and this one up nothing oh
cool
and take a whole bunch of these because
we're about to try to stealth again I'm
full up oh nice it's only carry five at
a time
all right so wonderful just that video
reviews going up this weekend they said
they're looking for video viewing
YouTube ah yes that's it's being worked
on
oh I wished Oh double wave oh no didn't
with that one on got that third time's
the charm
know that so go grab this one from this
guy again yeah everyone's heard about
what's this girl talk about going rip
down shop for a second you gotta give
them warning shots a false sense of
security scare a little bit Hugh
see you over there
someone said what is this we're playing
Metro Exodus because its launch day
we're playing the Xbox one
brought to you by Metro Exodus yeah yeah
I am by the crates that's a good call
yeah pick up give him a good girl
smack in the face
Ryan Smith said he hasn't made it far
enough before you get a new one however
you watch other channels they have a new
mask yeah I'm pretty sure gonna get a
new mass but yeah same with me I haven't
gotten far enough I still have I'm not
that far in the game how about you
you're a brother than I am you saw the
duct tape mask I never had so that's uh
that's a new thing for me oh I can't
break him out until I get arrested
guards let's just let's get you out of
here man was he still up on the train
yeah probably
oh yes I think I see his light on the
other side yes it is ducted pretty sure
hey you hello oh it's right there
oh there's a lot of boys down this way
Oh trouble I'm outta ammo people I'm out
of a lot of ammo don't shoot me please
hold on there we go oh he's hiding
behind the pillar give me away
y'all get out 1001 there you go let's
try to get a well has a good combat role
dude my dude hello it's okay it's all
right everything's fine
give me this ammo I need it more than
you do Ronald a shot that background
music though it's tense yes yeah I had
to like take one of my headphones it
loves playing is because this is huge
heads for everything very into it I can
take my mask off now - Sonia have to
deal with that okay can I let you out
now or is there someone else still
hiding there must now Ron it up here so
I think there's someone still in the
Train I haven't gotten yet like this guy
hello
see you all clear now we're good I said
to wait for Anna to give me the go-ahead
we don't have much time they'll be back
let's get on this train
you got there let's do it that mechanism
we made friends with this train guy
right music still going I feel like
we're about to get into a fight yep
there it is
Cavor me i appreciate when you get like
teammates that actually so like I just
saw that she's got that that sweet
tactical spot right now and she's
leading the charge just going for it
heck yeah oh I'll deejay when I'm ready
guys I got a little things I make sure
there isn't stuff for me to grab because
your boys really good at missing a shot
go think and if you're wondering yes
this is the beginning of the game we're
not very far in yeah we just started
sided to start at the beginning we don't
want to like spoil things too too late
in oh oh
I see barrels trying to foam up well
it's not there's a lot of stuff
springing out of them
we've got him okay there it is okay
everything's fine
Oh No explosions are very intense you're
telling me
[Music]
let's get that manual driver oh god
they're boys everywhere Robert Munoz
said you have to play the previous game
in order to understand the story it will
help you definitely it will add context
you should at least play last night
since this is like right after it I'd
say just playing to preserve a great
game
they also had like remakes recently I
think too
I'm shooting into the smoke I just saw
two guys out of the corner I think it
got him good good good yeah yeah yeah
teamwork
teamwork those explosions do ring very
loudly alarms going off everyone on the
train it's leaving Brunel we don't know
how long it takes to complete the game
because we haven't finished it I think
it actually says it in our review
or a quick review video don't know what
the number is
you can't impose from the Warhammer orcs
yeah it's a thing that I started doing
and I probably should lay off a bit it's
probably annoying
yikes oh that's a flash grenade my eyes
my ears the colonel
wait that's our boy Duke what's
happening here you know how I end up
here you were angry at me for going out
the first place hey you remember when
you lied to me about that thing that I
thought was true and I kept going out to
find it out you big jerk anyway look
forward to my my mobile DLC blog that I
put together where I just voice are you
graps what's going on out there of
course we have just made a huge mess but
my my immersion second all-time high
right now because I get to remember a
time I messed up in our shop actually do
kind of like that that detail of the
whole in your math it's really rad it is
immersive want the gray fox that I want
that been DLC and the tarts are people I
am - those are good boys
in Metro thinking the rest of the world
was in the war dang I'm I'm screwed for
a moment yeah you got it I get it
can you believe this is uncalled for you
wanna do better
Wow shoot it's the tugboat just kidding
it's not a boat it's another train
because there's no water around here
yikes oh it's such a fast tram to train
for hey I think we're about to have a
train fight man this would be really bad
if they had guns guns anyway our train
does not look equipped for this at all
yeah you tell him
placing blame left all right take some
responsibility
yeah I think I went into the scene with
my so we're alive indeed yeah whatever
this is where the guns are more like
valen force yeah kind of oh he's
definitely dead later oh you should have
taken his mask tonight I didn't think
that one through
he had to go it's gonna hit the fan that
will grab these I've grabbed these I
want to use my stealthy gun I'm not
gonna mess with those boys back there
oh hello for just can you just shoot
them in the air oh wait no you gotta sit
Oh this train is real shaky yes
oh he's not happy about that oh hello
get over there yeah get out of here
leave me alone anyway that was expertly
handled oh this guy's upset at me
don't shoot on the train you're gonna
blow yourselves up before it explodes be
careful respect the process it's all
your stuff oh no I got a hurry because
they're upset kick the door open let's
do it oh hi
yeah it's not like I are on this corner
I know there is oh there's a lot of guys
around this corner are they shooting at
me can't believe you guys you got him
I've never shot guns on a train but it
makes me think about what makes me
nervous what it would be like to
actually shoot guns on a train I don't
think it's a good idea yeah I wouldn't
do it who's gonna take all this it's
mine now
you are you a so leap joke a you're mad
get out of here yeah yeah did it now
what do we do you jump off I'll jump off
whoa Eddie jump off I can't read that
don't need to you just gotta go oh it's
it's like an emergency break okay cool
make that jump yep we're good we're not
good
we're the opposite of good pull yourself
up already am i swear to god
I did your stupid job watch this and yes
I do do parties booked me anytime was
real like like a Solid Snake kind of
moment like oh that one man just blew up
that in the Train
the only man for the job I did it sounds
really good though if you guys are just
see why Metro Exodus why is it so dark
it's a it's a dark yes like they it's
it's you know we don't hear that we
don't hear them read to us it's fine
we're good to keep going but I mean it's
post-apocalyptic you know everything's
rough next where do we go diary crews
content
yes it's all green double-checked it
stepmoms in the green - we don't need
masks here we don't match the truth cool
what's telling the truth why won't you
answer for those people trying to kill
us why would they shoot with you the
orders commander explain command choose
the only viable course of action to play
plan to ensure radio silence the shield
the system was created the network of
radio jammers covering Moscow and swords
I mean that's kind of believable like
you don't want to get nuked anymore
pretending that you're already all nuked
is pretty good could you not have shared
that before say before Artyom took that
radio outside and radiation people we
were securing a weather station see the
brightness little trains to dark ah
gotcha
all stations plan like getting some
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're giving us a sign Artyom figure
out how to work the radio
write down have a book in front of me
[Music]
the whole city on the ground with stores
and machines
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
grab it I can't toast if I don't pick up
my drink it is a good name good yeah hmm
I didn't finish it it's too spicy a
drink look at the map look at this map
I mean take a little bit probably oh we
have a destination think we're on our
way all right good
oh very sure
what is going on on this trance let's
check it out
no that's fine you're a really important
conversation you do all they'll talk to
the training chair
hey man where we headed some people out
here
fresh air it's real air I say so
was
dang get some some backstory possibly
from all the previous hand
is that new train simulator expansion
great box for any is this gonna be
awkward if I walk away from them always
talking anyway dad's here oh yeah I was
actually want to talk to me Oh time to
smoke sure yeah
man we just got into this fresh air
let's slide it up the railings are
really good to use even against dream
this is a state secret do you understand
I can fast I think I am
this price is still here it's still
going
speed smoking
do the people who kids yeah man I got it
hey man you want
it's not going anywhere I totally share
hide with ticket thank ya dude I feel
that what that is nice talking to you
talk talk to Matt after all those years
in the underground we're here the
surface seemed incredibly fresh
incredibly toxic a ting that was not
what had caused the crews euphoria our
journey finally got a definite purpose
provided by the transmission from the
government bunker if we reach it we'll
have to fight field goal a small team
against the occupation Army's what are
the chances that will succeed that will
get some answers we're sure to find out
in the next the next place we're headed
we got this it'll be fine
I've got Artyom and Anna so so I believe
it's in this new area of the air isn't
radiated so they're able to breathe
freely which is kind of cool
is this PC or console this is on the
Xbox one x so the strongest console you
can you could possibly do it's waiting
for it to load
mr. Audie how are you doing good to see
you oh yeah I hope everyone's having a
good Friday no matter what you you
decide to pick up and play headed into
the weekend very excited to get some
some sleep
haven't got a lot of that this week at
all yeah yeah and this is the third
installment series if you're not
familiar with the Metro series there was
Metro 2033 then Metro last light and
then Metro Exodus is the third one yeah
does the measure Exodus collector
edition come with a mask prop feels like
it should and duct tape you fix your own
your own holes that you do in your own
mask I'm going often having
misadventures the stream is not in 4k
lego man because we can't stream in 4k
but I believe it's X enhanced s-- should
be there we go now we're back in thanks
mr. Ali say good to see you guys really
glad to see you too you guys do enjoy
what you see you should definitely
follow the channel so you don't miss a
single stream we do stream every single
weekday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific all sorts
of things forgiveness get back to Metro
and his old life the life you had always
been running from and to think I never
believed you and now I'm looking at this
fog thinking it could actually be hiding
are no arrived from us by the way we
should be approaching the bridge soon I
see the bridge
it's there here shots oh boy
why would you set up your camp on the
train tracks what a foolish thing to do
well bogeys on a trolley can't believe
we hit that snow when I stopped our
whole train oh no
who was it any uniforms no they were
wearing rags
just some old farts Oh farts it's just
the perimeter guard they could put
anyone there and even women and children
well we can't be sure hmm I was
expecting to run into them much earlier
the trolley is headed towards the bridge
some fortifications there
this looks peaceful the village in a
church we need Intel here Artyom they
put the mark on your mouth ah a no job
for me chop covered this I'm gonna go do
it whatever these two can handle
themselves just fine
oh yes faith in me oh I see I see him
now to it I was like where's here he's
right underneath everything's okay I'm
right behind you
so to speak
heck yes inside you mean you knew
presents new gifts doesn't come with
crafting materials though so keep an eye
out for those guys fine
they're probably friendly men I'm hoping
they're just friendly there
even those who speak our language might
be enemies by conviction or a secure one
not even myself yeah it's a whole train
coming down the track
enslaved or something they're probably
just afraid that there are other people
around right Oh another slide it's the
little things you know
oh there's hole hole trains derailed
over here good question what I go in
here can't believe this doing my thing
you're some radiation going on this is
some crafting materials who just
probably had a better time somewhere
else it's not looking too good
I took a look around while you're inside
anything that electric tower there looks
like a perfect night for the position
let's go how much you want to bet we're
gonna have a sniper shot happen real
soon all right turn off my flashlight
let me to blind anyone this game is
really pretty yeah in fresh air look ah
I like it it's not a demon or a mutant
rabbit right it could be three eyes
hello Alfredo
good to see you hello mr. Audi we're
playing on normal
yeah I'm just playing on normal this is
not going to crazy since it's got a
pretty good challenge to it but nothing
too too crazy
I haven't haven't died yet did watch a
thing though hello I'll take that part
son now we can look at the the backpack
thing mode is this Howie
oh wow okay it's the first settlement
we've met so far need to find out who
lives here that's a pretty cool map I
like it
all these houses but not all of them let
me grab a few things but I wanna spend a
whole whole last bit of the stream
grabbing stuff one want some action
I'll climb up there while you take the
boat to the church you okay all right
cool see you late turn off that light
you too Oh got some real good boat
physics that's not a thing I like that's
giant crab monster I hope not Oh No
thank you
what are you doing here this bird is
fairly normal
who are you yeah okay see ya
there's a lot of these weird boys I mean
check it out
ah be upon ye oh this is gonna be
electricity is a sin my people we're
here nevermind I'm coming in wow this is
the weirdest Disney ride I've been on in
a while
[Music]
best seat in the house yes Bob Jones I
had some bad experience easy fish
yesterday I'm still not trusting the
fish in the waters someone who does a
kid speaking up
[Music]
who did start back you know maybe these
aren't my people I probably I probably
should pull pull them through okay well
just like go past them yeah let's go
want to hear what they're saying a bit
feel that good stuff the valet is gonna
take it from here we look very
threatening right now The Heretic is
trapped this is not what I needed I'm on
my there's a lot of stairs
not your lights
[Laughter]
year ago are you guys okay the breach
dwellers won't even talk to heretics but
I'll tell you everything I've seen on
displays all of that year seal antics
fool them just like the locals but I'm
like gasps oh cool oh man there's a lot
going on okay small boots oh man where
is he I can't find him so we're just
about to wrap up this dream we have
about a minute left but this is Metro
accident and I play the Xbox one
brought to you by Metro Exodus thanks
for providing the game for us to play
today yeah so yeah we played for the
beginning because we didn't want to
spoil too much you guys experienced it
yourself I'm just gonna keep going down
go for it
where do we end this thing it's probably
gonna be in a gunfight while I try to
get away we have to find let's put a pin
in this thing my boat's gone that's
supposed to go somewhere up there let's
just let's just run through it just make
out like a fast play and see what
happens no style at all action
got it Oh think he's over there
she might be over there who's down here
houses where everyone was punch him
right in the face
[Music]
that's not a good sound weld it yeah I
think I think this might be this might
be just where we we have tenex I don't
know for yeah head back up here see you
oh oh did I shoot his life head or
something that's not good to run past
you really quick you don't want to catch
on fire okay
it had every time he was I want to take
this damn ruthless heartless no I didn't
like what's going on here yeah I didn't
like what was going on in there either
let's take a look outside and then let's
wrap this thing up maybe a boat down
here there we go
this is our boat we're gonna oh this is
a trap actually yeah they're they have
tin cans posted up so they can hear me
coming to run through all of them
explicitly yeah we might yeah that's
fair all right well if you guys want to
play Metro Exodus go for it it's out
today we've been playing on xbox one
thank you to our friends at Metro Exodus
for sending us the game to play today
and yeah GameSpot live every day Monday
through Friday at 11 a.m. Pacific time
so come on by yes for joining us today
and we'll see you next time goodbye
everybody